you are a young civil engineer standing
on a construction site the Sydney
Harbour Bridge just 200 meters away is
barely visible a dust storm
originating in outback Australia has
blanketed Sydney in thick red dust which
hangs in the air like a San Francisco
fog you love your job from where you
stand from on that construction site
your office is a floating pontoon from
under your hardhat you're responsible
for work crews contract concrete
contractors and men your director of
Australia's largest rural scholarship
foundation you're a dear chairman of the
Sydney civil and structural panel if
these are your headlines they tell a
story of success but on the day that
dust storm blows into Sydney Harbour
your intuition whispers it's a sign as
clear as the visibility of low the
outback has sent you a message and on
this day you listen to your intuition
and you hand in your resignation when
have you listened to your intuition and
made a life-changing decision how will
you know your next job or your next
partner is the one when is your
intuition no longer a whisper but an
idea worthy of a microphone reason and
tradition have led us all to make good
decisions but intuition has led me to
make the greatest decision it just
starts with this little whisper and I'd
love to know what your whispers are and
I'd love to dare you to listen to them
I met J six years earlier in a small
outback town of just 300 people at all
unshaven shaggy head farmer smiled with
his whole body when I walked into that
bar underneath his Akoo bra were hazel
eyes and a big heart
the following week trying to impress a
certain girl a clean-shaven short-haired
farmer smiled with his whole body want a
dance love it was because of listening
to my intuition that I guess I knew what
to do next
standing in that dust on I handed in my
resume resignation I made a decision to
change Einstein said that the intuitive
mind is a sacred gift and the rational
mind is a faithful servant do we live in
a society that honors the servant but
has totally forgotten the gift we are
molded by educational institutions to
make the most rational decisions we are
seduced by a society to believe that
certain career paths will guarantee
success leadership courses preach what
successful careers should look like on a
graph of time versus success we are told
our career trajectories should move in
an upwards direction if I was to leave
Sydney I would drop right off that
career chart could you listen to your
intuition if it was just a whisper
amongst all this noise I resigned and I
followed my heart to outback Australia
to live on a 50,000 acre farm daring to
listen to my intuition help me break up
with the job I loved to chase the man of
my dreams when Harvard Business School
professor clay Christensen looked around
his 20-year reunion
he found an overwhelming proportion of
his classmates were unhappy just as
Einstein had predicted here were those
faithful servants of rational mind
seeking success in the external eyes of
society clay Christensen now teaches MBA
students to listen to themselves when
they make decisions to weigh up success
versus satisfaction walking off that
construction site I learn satisfaction
was the greatest measure for success but
it was the only one that it could
measure it
I arrived on the farm in the middle of
summer temperatures hit 120 degrees my
lipsticks melted across the front seat
of the car as we unpacked our life into
a timber homestead built 180 years ago
only five of the 20 rooms were livable
we were nine hours from Sydney four
hours from the airport two hours from
the nearest traffic light and a mile
from the mailbox a king down there was a
king brown snake under my office desk
and a pet kangaroo in the garden one
afternoon while driving back from
waterskiing the Sun was setting I had my
hand out the window catching the wind
thinking geez that project engineer in
Sydney would still be at work right now
my shoulders relaxed and I was smiling
with my whole body but I had no career
opportunities there were no jobs out
there so I spent a lot of time thinking
about what I really wanted to do and I
started my own engineering company my
engineering passion grabbed my
entrepreneurial spirit by the hand and
led me on a fabulous career adventure
have you had that feeling who would have
thought that that chick that walked off
that Wharf
but headed out to the outback would be
Australia's next young professional
engineer of the year that will create a
three billion dollar rural road plan
Society put me back on that success
chart by following my intuition by
chasing satisfaction I was quickly
accomplishing my dreams and in fact I'd
accomplished all my dreams why would
y'all whisper say at this point picture
the headlines of your future 30 40 and
50 year old self what are your whispers
what are you going to do today to ensure
your milestones milestones go to print
every morning around 10 a.m. Jay would
appear in the office window cut booty
love you can imagine my surprise after
three years of this routine when a
helicopter landed in front of the window
Jay jumped out from behind the controls
want a ride love those three years in
the outback had been the greatest ride
of my life but my intuition was starting
to question the reality of spending the
next 70 years as a farmer's wife versus
expanding my existing business versus
going global with an international
career in engineering what would you
know what to listen to
you are an engineer standing on a farm
in auerbach New South Wales you love
your job you love your lifestyle you
feel pressure to settle but you've made
someone else your first priority and
then you realize you haven't
accomplished all your dreams just the
ones you could reach while patiently
waiting at the bottom of someone else's
list your intuition whispers you're
standing at the river because you want
to cross it if you don't change
direction you will end up where you're
headed that is what I wrote on my
journal the day I left Sydney that is
what I looked at in my journal when I
started my company and perhaps I would
be right to make another decision now
four weeks ago the CEO and founder of
TaskRabbit boomed to the GSB you are the
change you've been waiting for
you're a generation uniquely equipped to
listen to your intuition you are more
equipped than ever and should be more
confident to make these decisions and
stick with them but you are the one you
were the change you've been waiting for
driving out that farm gate
I had no roadmap just this internal
assurance that with every mile I was
rewriting my own headlines I left behind
a house that I'd renovated into a home a
family and a farm that I would never
call mine my two beautiful black
Labradors and my boyfriend of nine and a
half years you intuitive ly know what
you want it's that little whisper that
just says
across the river we're all really scared
I dare you to break up with your
rational mind and chase your real dreams
imagine the adventure you might find
yourself on if you do it today imagine
the day
world leaders first verbalized their
whispers when Barack said to Michelle
want to run for president well when
Hillary said to Bill it's my turn now
babe imagine it is a process of
self-discovery and I love the quote from
Luna gand Australian philosopher come
sit down beside me I said to myself and
although it doesn't make any sense I
held my own hand as a small sign of
trust and together I sat on the fence
but don't sit on the fence too long take
action and just listen today is my 30th
birthday and I'm proud of the headlines
that have gone to print don't wait for
your 20 year reunion to consider what it
means to be satisfied don't wait for
your newspaper to go to print to read
about the headlines that you didn't dare
to chase you don't need a dust storm to
blow through campus you are the change
you've been waiting for
you